بعد زلزله تحدث عن الصدمه الصدمه لضحايا
والصدمه لكل الذين تابعوا الصور المؤلمه
لكن لا صدمه اكبر من تلك التي يعيشها
النجوم وبالحديث عن الصدمه دراسه اجراها
باحثون في كليه الطب في جامعه نيويورك
كشفت بالتفاصيل اثار هذه الصدمه ومن هذه
الاثار كشفت الدراسه ان الناجين من
الزلزال يكونون اكثر عرضه لاضطرابات النوم
ومشاكل للصحه العقليه حتى بعد عامين من
وقوع الحدث واضافه الى اضطرابات النوم
نتحدث عن الاكتئاب القلق والكثير من
الاثار المدمره ومن اللافت ايضا ان الاثار
كانت قويه حتى سنتين الى لميس
هناك الكثير من المشكلات الصحيه المحتمله
بعد وقوع الزلزال فحوالي من اثنين الى 15%
يمكن ان يعاني من اصابات سحق من الاحمال
الثقيله التي تسحق اجسادهم هذا يمكن ان
يؤدي الى مشاكله وفشل في الكلى وفي
الحالات الشديده حتى البتر الاصابات
العضلات والعظام الاكثر شيوعا المرتبطه
بالزلازل تتكون من تمزقات وكسور وكدمات
كما يعاني ضحايا السحق من نسبه عاليه من
التخثر المنتشر داخل الاوعيه الدمويه
ومتلازمه الطاقه التنفسيه لدى البالغين
كما يمكن ان يؤدي تزاحم الناس وتجمعهم في
المستشفيات او في اماكن مبيت واحد بعد
انهيار المنازل الى زياده فرص انتشار
الامراض المعديه ويتعرض الكثيرون
لاضطرابات نفسيه بعد معايشه الزلزال نتيجه
فقدان الاحبه او صدمه الحادث المفاجئ ما
يجعلهم تحت وطاه اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه
بخلاف المشكلات النفسيه الاخرى كالقلق
والاكتئاب
الولد
[موسيقى]
في خطوه تكشف محاولتهم استيعاب ما حدث
ومواجهه قلقيم المستمر من الهزات الارضيه
الاطفال المشردون بسبب الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا منذ اسبوعين تقريبا
بداوا يلعبون لعبه اسمها الزلزال هؤلاء
الاطفال ليضعون لبناء البنات بعضها فوق
بعض ويتساءلون هل هذا سيصمد امام الزلازل
هل هو مستقر كما يلعب الاطفال ايضا
بمجسمات لسيارات الاطفاء على هيئه لعبه
قائلين علينا الذهاب الى الزلزال بسرعه
فبحسب الاطباء يعالج الناس الصدمات بطرق
مختلفه فيما يحذرون بان اعداد المرضى
الذين يعانون من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه
ونوبات الصرع بعد الزلازل اخذه في الزياده
الوقت ليستوعبوا شو صار معهم ليعرفوا انه
اللي صار معهم شيء منه سهل مزبوط ليتقبلوا
انه في خسائر صارت يمكن خسروا بيتهم
عائلتهم
صحتهم بطريقه ما هيدا اول شيء اما بالنسبه
للاثار بتختلف عن كل شخص
الاغلبيه راح يعاني من اضطراب ما بعض
الصدمه
من نوبات الهلع من عدم القدره على النوم
ومن عده عده امراض اخرى يعني واحنا لاحظنا
فعلا الذين تم انتشالهم من تحت الانقاض في
ملامح صدمه على وجوههم كانه كمان حاله
انكار للواقع لدى البعض وكان شيئا لم يحصل
خصوصا عندما خرجوا اليوم هل تدوم هذه
النفسه ان الازمه النفسيه الى الابد ويبقى
ذكراها معلقا الى الابد ام نتحدث عن فئات
عمريه ستمحى هذه الكارثه من حياتهم
هلا طبعا اول شيء حكيتي عن حاله النكران
وهي حاله طبيعيه بالمراحل اللي بدي يقطع
فيها عدد كبير من الناجين كمان نقول كلهم
كرمال هيك انا قلت انه اول شيء لازم
نعطيونا الوقت قبل ما نقول لهم لازم تحكوا
لازم
تتعالجوا نحن حتكون نعطيهن ومساحتهم لحتى
يقدروا هن يستوعبوا اللي صار معه اكيد
طبعا اول فتره راح يكون في حاله نكران من
بعدها كل شخص بتبين تظهر عنده العوارض
بطريقه مختلفه عند الاطفال بتفرق غير عن
الكبار بس مش يعني الاطفال راح يضلوا كل
حياتهم معلقين بهذا الذكرى وكمان
الفكره انه كيف بنطلع منه بطريقه صحيه
ذكرى كتير كبيره بس بدل ما تضل تاثر علينا
بطريقه سلبيه كل حياتنا اذا عرفنا نطلع في
امرنا بطريقه مضبوطه بطريقه صحيه بيقدروا
نحول اذا بدك هالذكره القديمه
لعبره طيب يعني في اشخاص في ظروف مماثله
بصدمه ممثله استمرت معهم اعراض الصدمه
لسنتين وكل واحد عالج الصدمه بطريقته ما
هي الحلول او ما هي الطريقه المثلى للخروج
من هذه الصدمه بطريقه صحيه كما قلت ميه
بالميه هون بدنا نلجا للعلاج النفسي وطبعا
لطب النفسي ازول وكمان كل شخص
غير عن الثاني يعني ما فينا نجمل انه هيدي
الطريقه الوحيده
اللي بتحل هالمشكله طبعا الاطفال عندهم
طريقتهم بالتعبير عندهم اختصاصيين بس
شغلهم يخلوني عبروا بالطريقه الصح من خلال
الالعاب من خلال التمثيل في كذا طريقه عند
الاطفال معينه بيقدروا يخلوهم يعبروا عن
الشيء اللي صار معهم وطبعا اول ما يعبروا
بدنا نعطيهم اذا بدك الحريه
لانه طبعا رح يبكوا كتير يمكن رح يصارخوا
مثل ما حضرت لكم عم بتقولوا كنتوا كان عم
يخترعوا العاب وهيدا الشي
من خلال هذه الطرق نحنا بدنا نفوت معهم
بالطريقه اللي هن عم بعبروا فيها لا نقدر
نصلح لهم اياها
ودائما كانوا عم بيقولوا خلال فتره تغطيه
الزلزال انه ان جون يحتاجون اولا لحب
واهتمام ومن ثم اطباء نفسيا يعني الان في
هذه على ماذا ماذا يحتاجون هل يجب علينا
مثلا ان نقوم
فيما يتعلق بتهويل من هول الزلزال خصوصا
على الاطفال يعني نحن مثلا في حاله معينه
نذهب الى اطفالنا ونشرح لهم عن هذا
الزلزال وهذه الكوارث التي يمكن ان تحصل
في المستقبل بالتالي قد يكون مستعدين هل
هذا وارد
صح الاطفال لو لو نحن بنعتبرهم انه هن
صغار يعني فينا شو منقولن يمكن يصدقوا بس
هون كمان لازم ننتبه ونتحمل هذه المسؤوليه
يعني نحن ما فينا نقول لهم انه لا ما في
وجود ابدا لشيء اسمه كوارث طبيعيه ما في
وجود ابدا لزلزال نحن بدنا نجرب نكون
واقعيين معهم قد ما بنقدر طبعا اول فتره
مزبوط مثل ما قلت يعني اهم شيء انه نضل
حواليهم نستجيب لطلباتهن الجسديه
اذا بدك الايموشن
فهونه اول بارت الثاني لا طبعا بدنا نشرح
لهم بدنا نقول لهم انه اللي صار طبعا هو
يمكن ما بصير دائما بالحياه بس هو امر
بصير وفي كثير اشخاص ممكن تتعرض له
مش لازم نخوفهم منه بس بذات الوقت لازم
نشرح لهم انه هيدا امر طبيعي هذا امر يمكن
يواجهنا بالحياه شكرا جزيلا نورتينا في
الاستوديو الاخصائيه النفسيه الينا حداد
شكرا لك شكرا لالكم